you probably don't need this card and
are actively making your Mana base worse
for no reason let me explain most decks
shouldn't care about discarding to hand
size because it's not actually a problem
unless three things are true one you're
running a lot of draw hand size
naturally reduces over time unless you
miss land drops or don't play spells so
to need the extra hand size you need
enough draw to counteract this and then
some two the cards in your deck can't be
played fast enough either because
they're high Mana or because they're
reactive if your deck is full of 1 to
three drop permanence you'll probably be
able to play them before getting too
many in hand three the cards in your
deck are valuable enough that you
actually want to keep all of them you
might want to keep all your counter
spells in specific Tech pieces but you
don't need four lands and five generic
six drop creatures in your hand even if
you meet all three of these criteria you
might still be fine with a max hand size
recursion flashback cards discard
synergies and things that count cards
and graveyard all exist and you get to
pick what to discard that's pretty cool
at the end of the day card selection
usually trumps card quantity by a wide
margin unless you have a marrow out so
please draw without fear even if you
have to discard you'll be okay